in October of 2020 Major General Ed
Thomas who at the time was the uh
commander of the Air Force Recruiting
service wrote an oped for Yahoo news and
was it was entitled 86% of Air Force
pilots are white men here's why this
needs to change in about 800 words Major
General Thomas outlined his plan to
recruit Pilots without regard for their
competence or Fitness or their loyalty
to the United States instead Thomas
explained the most important thing for
the Air Force to focus on was the skin
color of its recruits he said that
hiring more black and brown recruits was
vital in order to keep Pace with Russia
and China you know they're busy
developing Hypersonic missiles that can
fly at like 20 times the speed of sound
but the general wrote you know uh and
and you know the real the real secret
sauce for us that keeps us competitive
is uh diversity and according to Ed
Thomas quote our goal is to get in front
of every demographic group in America
and show them someone who wears a flight
suit every day that they can look up to
and say that could be me now three years
after he wrote that oped and launched
the Air Force's anti-white recruitment
plan Major General Ed Thomas retired so
he inflicted his Dei recruitment
strategy on the Air Force and then he
quickly left so he doesn't have any
reason to care about the consequences
but especially as World War III seems
more plausible by the day the rest of us
have an important question to ask which
is how did this Dei strategy turn out
exactly Thomas's replacement a general
named Christopher amrhein test T ified
this month before the Senate armed
services committee and he informed
Congress when he testified that for the
first time in 24 years the Air Force has
failed to meet its basic uh recruitment
goal and I'll say that one more time for
the first time in more than two decades
the Air Force didn't hit its recruiting
objective so they were they were trying
to expand their recruitment they were we
were told they were expanding it to to
to reach more people and in
response they got fewer people in fact
it was off by around 10% which is uh
which is a major uh Miss and they're not
alone amrhein went on to testify that
the Army and Navy which also put a new
emphasis on recruiting minority
candidates also fell far short of their
projections in the most recent fiscal
year which ended in September he
testified that quote we've seen a steady
decline in the military even being an
option for our youth as they contemplate
the future now if you crunch the numbers
you'll find that that's actually a
massive understatement in total the
military missed its recruitment goal by
more than 40,000 individuals the Army
now has about 450,000 active duty
soldiers its smallest size since 1940
before the US entered World War II in
all the US military currently has around
1.4 million active service members and
by comparison China's military has more
than 2 million now as alarming as all
those statistics are uh the news gets
even worse when you consider the quality
of the few people who are still signing
up to serve this country The Daily Mail
reported this week on what it calls a
tick tock Mutiny among recruits who are
increasingly posting videos online to
complain about the conditions they're
shocked to encounter in the military
these are people in the military in full
uniform making Tik Tok videos
complaining um and often recording
themselves inside US military bases
whining that the pay is bad uh the food
isn't up to their standards and many
other types of complaints here are just
a couple of those videos check
now these are my top five reasons on why
you shouldn't join the military reason
number one is pay we do not get paid
enough for what we do I'm not here to
say that we get paid pennies I'm just
saying that we don't get paid enough to
perform the mission that is tasked to us
reason number two family you will not
see your family often you might see them
on holidays and and that that's about it
I can elaborate reason number three
schooling now I know you're like whoa
that was a benefit but it's requirements
you have to meet first to be able to get
to that schooling so if you're thinking
about joining because of schooling just
go to school reason number four if
you're a parent now if you join single
and get married and then have kids
that's one thing but if you're already
having a channel you're thinking about
joining don't you got to think about it
boot camp is between 6 to 8 weeks after
boot cam you go to school that's between
10 days to a year after that you go to
deployment that's between 8 months to 9
months think about how much time you
miss with your child reason number five
you do not have 100% say on what you
want to do
[Music]
five reasons why you shouldn't join the
Army why you should not join
the Army all right number one I know
what y'all I know what yall want to hear
to
pay starting off
like first like E1 I'm pretty sure you
making like 1,600 a paycheck and that's
like not they cut it there you get the
you get the idea it goes on and on and
on the reasons are all the same too and
these are all things that I guess
surprised these guys like they didn't
they didn't see that coming the fact
that you're not going to be able to see
your family when you're at boot camp was
that like did you not know that and
you'll notice that nowhere in those Tik
Tok videos do any of the soldiers and
there's a lot of them out there um a lot
of these Tik Tok videos nowhere do they
talk about like their pride in the
country or
their family's history of service or
their desire to ensure a safe and
prosperous world for their grandchildren
they don't talk about any of that
because none of that applies to them a
recent poll by Gallup found that only
one in 10 Young liberals were extremely
proud in their country one in 10 and
since Mo most young people are liberal
well this is what you get now on the
bright side um it is a diverse group of
soldiers in these clips and you watch
any of these videos from the Tik Tock
Mutiny uh it's very very diverse lots of
non-white males lots of females as well
making these kinds of videos there's no
denying that very diverse so that's at
least one objective that our Pentagon
has successfully completed unfortunately
all of these diverse recruits are saying
pretty much the same thing though
they're not making enough money they're
not getting enough respect they can't
see their families as often as they like
to so on and so on now of course all of
these complaints have always applied to
life in the military the food has never
been from what I've told fstar quality
uh the pay has always been abysmal
you've always had very little control
over your life because you know the
military decides what you do and where
you go the difference is that now we're
filling the ranks with the sorts of
people who would not only whine about it
but whine publicly in uniform on video
for
clicks these are the kinds of recruits
that we're told are going to help us
defeat China and their Hypersonic
missiles
this is what Equity looks like in the
armed forces and no one's allowed to
point out what a disaster it's been but
it has been a
disaster but the issue isn't just
diverse recruitments uh recruitment
efforts and Tik toks there are much
deeper problems with the military's
leadership and uh a handful of recent
incidents give us Clues as to what these
deeper problems are so last December the
Washington Times reported that the
defense department launched an
investigation into two army soldiers who
quote took took sexually explicit photos
in uniform while wearing dog masks and
bondage gear now some of those photos
were apparently taken on an Airfield as
well as inside a locker room with name
plates for joint based Pearl Harbor
nothing ever came of that investigation
in fact we mentioned it on this show uh
but as far as I could tell the military
just buried it and nothing came of it
that same month a high ranking commander
in New Jersey named Chris Schilling who
was stationed at Joint Base Maguire Di
Lakehurst uh threatened a mother on
Facebook because she complained about
gay propaganda that her seven-year-old
daughter was learning at school so
here's what the mother Angela reading
wrote on Facebook quote why are
elementary schools promoting allowing
elementary kids to research topics of
sexuality how can my young CH children
be accepting of people who are sexually
attracted to multiple genders they don't
know what sex
is now our post continued along those
points and uh along those lines and
makes a very valid very point at no
point did she threaten anyone but in
response Chris Schilling wrote this
quote The Joint Base leadership takes
this situation very seriously from the
beginning have had the security forces
working with multiple State local Law
Enforcement Officers agencies to monitor
the situation to ensure the continued
safety of the entire
Community now in this case the military
never explained why Chris Schilling was
posting publicly on behalf of a military
base and intimidating a mother who was
expressing her views on social media
they certainly didn't publicly fire
killing which would have been obviously
appropriate again they just buried the
story a majority of gen Z supports
left-wing policies like open borders and
socialism if we don't reach them and
change their minds the country we know
and love will be lost forever prageru is
the leading nonprofit when it comes to
influencing young people prageru's
educational entertaining pro-american
videos meet young people where they are
online and open their minds to the truth
but they need your help go to
prageru.com make a tax able donation
whatever you give right now will be
tripled and have three times the impact
donate $10 it triples to $30 give $100
it triples to $300 prageru is 100% free
to everyone with no fees or
subscriptions they don't rely on ads or
clickbait headlines contrary to what the
left says Prager U isn't funded by a
handful of billionaires it's funded by
people just like you in order to keep
making great content reaching millions
and changing Minds prageru needs your
help go to prageru.com to donate today
Christmas is coming and while you're out
shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with rough
greens naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of rough greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
Ruff greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food just sprinkle rough Greens
on their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are wheat and that goes for dogs
too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is so
confident Ruff greens will improve your
dogs Health he's offering my listeners a
free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it get a free jump start trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com or call 844 ru700 it's rfffg
greens.com or call 844 ru700 today now
each of these incid as egregious as they
are point to the transformation of the
US military from a fighting force into a
political tool their goal now is the
same as the goal of every Federal agency
under the bid Administration which is to
promote a perverse cult and root out any
non-believers that's why three years ago
the Pentagon commenced a political Purge
that was thinly veiled as a covid
mandate in just the past few years more
than 8,000 military service members were
discharged for refusing to take the co
shot could that be one of the reasons
why the numbers are
down um now only around 40 of those
service members ever returned they're
mostly gone for good because the point
wasn't really to keep service members
from dying of Co it was to punish people
with wrong political
views and now you know the people who
want to sign up are as we see in some of
these Tik Tok videos many of them are
sort of entitled and
lazy you know it's easy to make this
into a commentary on gen Z and that's
what some a lot of the the the you know
analysis on this has been has been
focused on that well gen Z they're all
they're all lazy this is how they are
and to some extent sure it's a
commentary on them but it's more a
commentary on our institutions that have
created people like this and a military
like this the biggest problem for the
military right now and it's it is a very
major problem is that they're not only
light in numbers but in the quality of
the recruits they're bringing
in you know it used to be that the
military would actively recruit young
men and call them to come and sacrifice
themselves in defense of their country
they were looking for men who could kill
the
enemy like they're looking for for
people who are going to who are going to
go out and kill the bad guys and they
didn't hide from that fact Full Metal
Jacket is a fictional film obviously but
by all accounts its depiction of Marine
Corps boot camp 50 years ago isn't too
far from accurate and uh in one iconic
scene the drill sergeant tells the
recruits that they need to become
killers and then gives Charles Whitman
and Lee Harvey Oswald as examples of
effective Marine Corps assassins now
that's not the kind of speech that we
would want drill sergeants giving in
reality Mass murderers aren't really the
best Role Models but the point is that
the military didn't used to hide from
the fact that it was calling men to
violence violence for a good cause in
service to their country but violence so
you see here three things that are now
missing from the way the military
recruits and trains people they used to
look for one men who were two two
motivated by higher ideals like
patriotism and were three eager and
willing to kill bad
guys the military's current recruitment
strategy specifically avoids all of
that now they put out recruitment ads
that look like Disney movies or you know
the kinds of videos you might see in a
corporate HR
seminar so here for example we played
this on the show a long time ago but
just one recent recruitment ad from the
Army it specifically targets women who
are motivated not by Patriot ISM
certainly not by a desire to go out and
kill the enemy but really by by
narcissism
watch this is the story of a soldier who
operates your nation's Patriot missile
defense
systems it begins in
California with a little girl raised by
two
moms
although I had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet played violin I
also marched for
equality I like to think I've been
defending freedom from an early
age when I was 6 years old one of my
moms had an accident that left her
paralyzed doctor said she might never
walk again but she tapped into my
family's Pride to get back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other
mom with such powerful Role Models I
finished high school at the top of my
class and then attended UC Davis where I
joined a sorority full of other strong
women but as graduation approached I
began feeling like I'd been handed so
much in life a sorority girl stereotype
sure I'd spent my life around inspiring
women but what had I really achieved on
my
own one of my sisters was studying
abroad in Italy another was climbing
Mount
Everest I needed my own
Adventures okay so you get the idea and
that that recruitment ad is a couple
years old uh I think at this point so
you see this drop off in recruitment
that that now the Pentagon is telling us
about and it's a real crisis um and it's
like you can it's like right around when
that ad went out is when things started
to
plummet and you can see why this is uh
you know an ad first of all that that
video like you could take that exact
video the way it looks sounds everything
and that could easily be a video that
maybe they'd show you if you work at
Target uh about how they recruit people
for their Management program at
Target except this is the
military so we see a strong and
independent woman raised by two lesbians
to become a left-wing social justice act
activist we're told that she grows up
gets hired by the Army and you know then
later she talks about how she gets to
boss men around doesn't want to serve
her country she wants to use her job in
the Army to uh like impress her sorority
sisters it's all about me and I it's
about my adventure I want to do
something for
me this is kind of the person the
military has been targeting and this is
the way they've been targeting them it's
not just the Army that's been trying to
remove all hints of masculinity from its
ranks as Matt Gates pointed out this
year Malmstrom uh Air Force Base Montana
recently hosted a drag queen Story Hour
so did Nellis Air Force Base in Nevada
uh Joint Base Langley and Virginia all
had drag queen story hours this year
amid all the scrutiny the Pentagon
reluctantly announced that the Navy has
suspended its formal drag queen events
and that led to maybe the single most
depressing but perhaps unintentionally
hilarious news conference ever delivered
by the Department of Defense watch can
you this uh this drag queen recruiting
initiative is that strictly a Navy
project are you going to have the other
services also get involved is it going
to be an army drag queen Air Force drag
queen that sort of thing is it strictly
Navy project well I would say first and
and at the the top just looking at this
holistically we are incredibly proud of
those who decide to serve and that's
every Young American who decides to to
serve and to take the oath um to put
their line on the line in defense of our
country um again the the program I
believe that you're referring to was the
Navy digital ambassador program which
was a pilot Outreach effort it was not a
recruiting effort uh for more
information on that I would direct you
to the Navy um but this pilot program
has concluded and the Navy is evaluating
the program and how it ex exists in the
future so the drag queen initiative was
suspended says the Pentagon lady but the
military never apologized for it they
never reacted with horror that this was
going on in the first place instead
they've uh just done they've been doing
the past few years which is that they
buried it tried to move on admitted no
fault and uh but then also kind of just
kept on doing what they were doing
before and here's the reality that all
this kind of stuff lowering standards
filling the military with cultists who
hate this country uh this is not the
solution to low recruitment everybody
knows that the solution to low
recruitment is to first of all apologize
for firing soldiers because they won't
take an experimental shot re State all
those soldiers with back pay immediately
then fire any officer who had any
involvement in that decision including
Lloyd Austin then the Pentagon needs to
repudiate the testimony of former Joint
Chiefs of Staff chairman Mark Millie who
repeatedly lectured soldiers about quote
white
rage instead of pretending that white
supremacy is the biggest threat we face
and making cartoon recruitment videos
for narcissistic girl bosses the
Pentagon should do what it used to do
which is reward Merit and character and
most of all if you want to solve your
recruitment problem you need to speak to
men specifically and call them to
service using language that evokes
higher ideals like patriotism and
courage and
loyalty and then you need to turn the
military turn it back rather into a
place tailor made for men like
that now under the current
administration of course the military
will do precisely none of that that's
because from the various highest levels
the B Administration doesn't believe
this country or its values are worth
defending
the end result is the crisis that the
military currently faces and it is
indeed a crisis but it's a crisis of
their own making if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed